foreign
[Music]
pixel sevens seven and seven per I'm
using these songs for about a week now
and yes they are very similar to last
year they're the same prices too but
more than ever this year and you can see
it at every corner the pixel special is
software solutions to Hardware problems
and this is in contrast to say the
Samsung or the xiaomi special which is
throw as much raw Hardware horsepower at
the thing as possible there's just no
way that isn't better than before and
there's nothing right or wrong with
either of these approaches matter of
fact as a Tech head you can kind of
appreciate both but there is there is
just a little bit of a magic to this
software way at least when it works so
yeah I can definitely appreciate the
slightly updated Hardware on the outside
of the pixel because even though it
isn't super important to the Google
Mission it's still important to the
users so initially with my very first
Hands-On I didn't love it but it's kind
of growing on me the main change here
being the metal camera bar instead of
the All Glass visor from last year it
lets them do some interesting stuff with
the colors but most importantly lets
them make it all one piece of metal all
the way around with the frame of the
rest of the phone it's polished aluminum
on the pro and matte aluminum on the
pixel 7. then both phones also get
brighter displays up to 1500 nits Peak
on the 7 Pro and 1400 nits on the
regular pixel 7. can't fake that with
software and then the 7 Pro display is
larger slightly curved over the edges
and a generally better looking display
with less off-axis rainbowing but
interestingly it's set to 1080p out the
box by default even though it's a 1440p
panel I immediately switched that to
1440 and have had no battery issues so I
recommend doing that matter of fact
might as well just say it right off the
top I have had great battery experiences
with these phones I've been mostly
dailying the 7 Pro David at the studio
has been dailying the seven and yeah
they've been excellent like just this
morning today drove into the studio had
an hour-long commute with Waze on full
brightness GPS streaming Spotify audio
through Bluetooth to the car got here
with like 85 battery left and I'm
consistently ending days with 30 to 40
percent six to seven hours is not a
problem uh yeah I've had very good
battery life on these phones very
impressive that's a combination of
software optimization better modems just
better chip overall
but speaking of chips inside the phone
there are very few new specs but the new
second generation tensor G2 from Google
is one of them there's also a little bit
extra RAM on the pro phone it does
Benchmark a bit higher than the first
tensor but in terms of raw power it's
right in line with the Snapdragon 865
fine but just like I talked about in the
problem with benchmarks video which you
can watch here if you haven't seen it
already Google is optimizing this tensor
G2 chip to work more efficiently
specifically with its AI stuff it's AI
magic so while yeah the G2 is a little
faster than the first tensor with its
smaller four nanometer process node the
real improvements are in its machine
learning capabilities which are 60
faster and 20 percent more efficient
than last year so the things that
actually require those AI smarts are
dramatically better and faster so that
is where it starts to get interesting
not to dismiss the you know slight
improvements of the pixel overall I mean
you can see they even they painted
inside the port and the speakers down
here to match the rails of the phone
it's nice I like it but that's not what
the pixel is all about the pixel is the
software it is the smartest smartphone
and pretty much all the reasons you'd
pick a phone like a pixel 7 over the
rest are in the software like for phone
calls for example pixel is the only
phone with call screening which to me is
still super useful but it also goes to
another level so when you call a
business that has an automated system
the improved direct my call feature will
surface all the buttons at once so you
can press to navigate through an
automated system before the robot even
finishes saying them it saves me so much
time I love that I also like the new
home screen search which still has all
the great functionality as before it's
just cleaner and better designed and
then with the new selfie camera the
pixel has added AI based Face Unlock
which is great but as you can see it's
just a single selfie camera up top here
there's no infrared depth mapping or
face ID equivalent so while it's super
fast in great conditions it absolutely
struggles as expected when you're in the
dark or when you have a mask on so
there's also still an under display
fingerprint reader for dual biometric
authentication anytime Face Unlock fails
I will say I was hoping that the
fingerprint reader would be one of the
things that improved to the pixel 7
Hardware wise because the one in the six
was a little bit of a letdown for me
it's it's not noticeably bigger or
faster it's fine it's not
terrible it's just a slight step behind
the ultrasonic ones which are noticeably
faster than this Optical one oh also the
recorder app most some people don't even
care about this but the recorder app is
better it's already the best in the
world at doing incredibly fast and
accurate speech to text you've seen this
before thanks tensor but I got an
amazing demo of somebody starting a
recording and then putting the phone in
their pocket and we had a full-on
conversation they took the phone out of
their pocket and it had perfectly
transcribed our entire conversation with
speaker labels so each time the opposite
person spoke it labeled that
incredibly useful or incredibly creepy
depending on who you are but that's one
of the features that's allegedly coming
later this year to an update I'm going
to be using that and it just definitely
feels like anywhere you go on this phone
Google assistant is waiting right around
the corner waiting to help you out it
was the same with the last pixel Android
13 got its improvements with material U
and the under the hood improvements but
just the Google stuff everywhere the
routines the little reminders the little
chip cards words and messages for
helpful things you might want to do to
add to a message there's a lot of good
stuff there's even a new feature called
photo unblur you might have seen the
demos basically takes any photo in your
pixel 7's Library actually anything in
your Google photos library at all and if
it's a little bit blurry you hit that
unblur button and it can use AI to
identify what the scene should look like
and fix the photo remove the blur seems
super cool so okay after trying this
with a bunch of photos we found that it
seems to work best specifically with
photos of subjects that are in Focus but
the exposure time was too long and so
now there's a bit of blur in One
Direction in that exact instance I found
it can do a pretty good job of turning a
streaky blurry photo into something much
more usable I wouldn't expect anything
magical but you know this is pretty cool
it's the definition of using software to
solve Hardware problems also if they do
say pixel 7 exclusive for this feature
for now
I don't really buy it they say it's
because of temps or G2 I give it about a
year before this feature is available
for more phones maybe anyone using
Google photos but hey for now gotta have
a pixel 7. but the point is Google is
not setting out to make a phone with the
absolute best hardware and the best
display and the absolute best raw
performance I mean if they are they're
failing but Google pixel is absolutely
the smartest smartphone in the room it's
the smartest phone you can get and it's
even more true again this year now the
pixel has been known for one other thing
probably as long as anything else and
that's the cameras and there's an
updated Suite of cameras on the front
and the back of the pixel 7s this year
so the 50 megapixel primary camera is
the same on both same as last year the
pro gets a new even wider Ultra wide
with autofocus while the 7 keeps the one
from last year and the pro also gets a
new 5x 48 megapixel telephoto camera and
as expected the pixel 7 and 7 Pro take X
excellent photos in a variety of
different lighting conditions and they
have that very distinct pixel style the
high dynamic range contrasty lots of
detail those shots this big sensor can
create some pretty nice natural depth of
field still without using portrait mode
I love that I know I shouldn't be super
impressed that you know normal daylight
photos look great on the pixel but hey
these are really really good and then
the new Pro Ultra wide does a really
good job with macro photography doesn't
do macro video but this photo of an ant
is really hard to get and the auto
switching to macro mode can be disabled
if you're like me and prefer taking
close-up photos of things with the main
camera just be aware of minimum Focus
distance but then here's another great
example of solving Hardware problems
with software the zoom so the One X
camera still normal 1X that's a 50
megapixel main sensor binning down to 12
megapixels the 2x button is a 12
megapixel crop of the middle of the
frame so a high quality Zoom then from
2x to 5 5x the camera is actually doing
some composition it's adding detail in
the middle of the frame from the
telephoto camera and then compositing
them together then you get to 5x and
it's snapping to the full telephoto
camera that makes perfect sense then
again the 10x is taking a 12 megapixel
crop of the middle of the telephoto so
another high quality zoom and it's
pretty good I will say it's not quite as
good as having a dedicated 10x telephoto
camera on the back of the phone like
having a dedicated camera is always
going to give you the sharper overall
image but for someone like me who only
zooms once in a while the whole super
resume software solution is very
passable as you can see and then that
saves you money and then you get the
zoom stabilization that activates at 15x
and it is really really stable maybe a
little too stable sometimes because it
kind of makes it hard to track like
moving objects which I know you love to
do when you're creeping I mean bird
watching anyway yeah the pixels camera
right still top of the Heap when it
comes to point and shoot Android cameras
the shutter speed is super fast so if
you're trying to freeze motion and also
capture like an exact moment this camera
is really good at that the selfie
cameras on both are also improved it's
now an 11 megapixel selfie camera they
both do ultra wide selfies now instead
of just the pro love that and video is
slightly better too including 10-bit HDR
tough to show that in this SDR video but
if you've seen HDR video before you know
where this excels already anything with
bright specular highlights loads of
dynamic range Etc it's still a step
behind the iPhone when it comes to noise
levels and autofocus so for those
curious why I still put the iPhone as
the overall king of smartphone imagery
that's why but this is not far behind by
any means okay here's a couple other
small things that didn't fit into the
rest of this review the speakers on the
7 Pro are slightly louder but slightly
less Bassy than the 6 Pro just a little
tinier so a little less low end for a
little bit more vocal Clarity I found
that interesting and then there's not a
whole lot going for sustainability for
these phones other than the metal visor
and frame being made with 100 recycled
materials some pretty specific wording
there but also the box that comes in
which doesn't have a charger does come
with a cable and an adapter and is fully
recyclable cardboard and then a big
question are there bugs because my pixel
6 experience was a roller coaster I mean
I I love the phone to start but then
it's slowly descended into having more
and more bugs until I it was like
unusable to me and I stopped using it
then it got some updates that squashed
those bugs and then I ended up dailying
it for like the last two months or so so
all their bugs on the pixel 7s yeah I
have found some I mean I had this media
player bug where it just shows a blank
space where the media player is supposed
to be whether or not there was any media
playing that did go away after reboot
there was also this weird thing where
after you hit the X in the Google search
bar that button just disappears but it's
still pressable for some reason also I
tried to post the Instagram story from
the pixel 7 Pro the other day and it
just looked like this for some reason
honestly no idea what happened here
everyone saw it apparently some people
thought it was an ad for dbrand's new
digital camo it wasn't but this is hey
if your new metal bar isn't enough and
you want your new pixel to look even
more different from the rest Channel
sponsor dbrand's new skin is pretty sick
and it's a foolproof way to make your
phone look unique plus it hopes to hide
that dust that sort of naturally
accumulates right above and below the
camera bar so link below of course right
below that like button but I've really
enjoyed using the pixel and that's why
it's going in my pocket as my daily
driver phone for now anyway
as far as whether you should get one or
not I think the real question is how
much money are you willing to spend
because same prices as last year 5.99
8.99 and I think my initial feeling is I
still feel the same which some people
got kind of Twisted by the way but the
300 difference between these phones the
pixel 7 is a way better deal than the 7
Pro like they're both well priced and
they're both very competitive and
frankly undercutting most of what
they're competing against but the seven
is just for most people a no-brainer so
uh this is the phone I'm gonna be
recommending more often probably a value
phone of the Year Contender again look
there's a lot of stuff Google didn't do
with the pixels like they didn't do
super fast 80 watt charging they didn't
do multiple telephoto cameras it doesn't
even fold in half right there's a lot of
stuff but for patient Pixel People Who
prefer pristine programming and pretty
pictures the pixel Pro is
pretty perfect
[Music]